cuphead people are loving cuphead it's
got ten out of ten on Steam thousands of
user reviews you guys seem to love it as
well and I criticized Game Journalists
for being bad at the game now that the
game has been out a couple of days let's
see what major gaming media outlets are
saying about cuphead I find cup heads
difficulty infuriating not fun okay that
was kataka what about polygons
please don't let cup head speedruns make
you feel bad about yourself don't feel
bad about being bad at games just don't
feel bad please can we have a moment of
silence for all the bad gamers can we
please I find it really interesting how
there's such a difference between gamer
and a game journalist with movie reviews
I tend to listen to critics more because
they're professional it's their job they
know how to analyze movies differently
than your typical eye but with games it
just seems like the complete opposite I
listen to what the audience review is
rather than the critic review because
when you're this bad at games why should
I listen to what you have to say about
the game is hard yes but it's not
impossible
cuphead really sparked the debate on
difficulty in games and it even came out
an article saying can we have our skip
boss fight bottom now Game Journalists
wants to have a skip boss fight button
[Music]
but they really laid the foundation of
this article very nicely I would say
those who spread toxicity are those most
likely to be on the side of condemning
gaming options that remove challenge so
anyone that wants a gaming challenge
you're spreading toxicity okay you need
to tone it down a bit
because you're being quite toxic right
now can you imagine how annoying it must
be that have a challenging bossfight and
then there's just this skip boss button
dangling right next to your face like
are you sure oh jeez this boss is a
little difficult are you sure you don't
want to skip this one buddy look come on
click me that's got to be the worst idea
I've ever heard the journalist also
tweeted anyone who ever uses the word
gameplay needs to seriously consider
their life choices what the heck is
wrong with gameplay hasn't PC gamer
banned the word from its article I
should bloody hope so
what did I miss here what happened what
happened I don't want to say I just
don't understand I did a little bit of
digging to understand why gameplay is a
trigger word apparently for a game
journalist and apparently it's because
it minimizes video games as an art form
telling developers how they should make
games minimizes games as an art form ok
cuphead knows what he wants to be and it
sticks with it it's not made for a wide
audience and he doesn't have to be and
the people that do love it love it and
that's why it's getting so much praise
lastly no one cares like if I had a
friend that was bad at a video game I
wouldn't actually care all these means
about like get good or no casuals it's a
joke like how hurt can you be from it
please don't let cut pic speedruns make
you feel bad I probably taught way too
much and I honestly just want to play
the game so I'm just gonna do that okay
a lot of you guys pointed out I didn't
actually equip my goddamn extra heart
point
[Music]
I'm thinking I'm gonna go with the
automatic carry though so you haven't
equipped any of it it's so stupid see
you know even even a pro gamer like
myself will make mistakes oh cool I'm in
a plane weight shrink oh it's like okay
hey cruel whoa
so cool oh it's a visit a box Oh shoes
she literally killed me with a laugh
attack
[Music]
that's a meanie right there
she became a cow everybody or a pole
[Music]
okay well clearly I've already failed
there's no way yeah there you go
Wow good job Felix
let me change extra hit points it would
probably do me better here yes own
everybody Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
why am i so bad what the heck man stop
oh no oh no I'm gonna be here a while
oh no so apparently this game was made
literally just by three people how crazy
is that gosh damn man apparently also
they had to take out a more a second
mortgage on their house just to be able
to afford funding the game now tonight's
it's pretty cool
it shows the passion of wanting to make
something what is happening it might a
bomb that's a little offensive
okay now you went too far cut head I'm
so bad at this boss I don't blow this so
cool what is happening okay this
I made it halfway that time thanks mom
I'm in trihard mo now it happened
finally I'm doing amazing though this is
it mom I don't wanna dodge that I did it
[Music]
shoes
[Music]
love the music to this kind of thing I
would snap my fingers too if you know
what I mean Oh Oh what what it mean stop
I'm a bomb I hit the wrong thing all
right we're getting there oh clothesline
what is she doing what is she doing what
is she doing what is happening oh whoa
what the heck er that's so cool why
would you want to skip a boss this is so
doe Oh shoes I almost got it okay I'll
get it this time
so it's random which one they turn into
oh I don't know how to dice this okay
just go around
oh I love it
SoDo if we get into Perry I'm not gonna
get super now god damn it
no come on one more life come on
yes nice listen all right whatever
okay all right and don't look don't look
hey hey put a plate hey hey hey shut up
nope nope no it said a-plus everyone
knows it it's the F I wonder what's
inside his cup you know milk drinks milk
and a cup I don't this is a Perry helmet
well I miss these levels these are fun
it wasn't Mary how do i Perry stop no
yeah leave me alone
whoa whoa whoa it's mr. pecker I've
missed the parrot gosh
what that was all okay all right here we
go
no come back
I want the coins here we go what's the
hacker man what the woodpecker give up I
give up
[Music]
where's my double jump huh what it put
in there stop stop it
ah this this hill sucks okay let's oh my
god this game sucks I slap that stupid
thing great hidden coin got it go wait
oh my god what the heck this game is
impossible
don't feel bad Felix just don't feel bad
about being bad
there's nothing worse about than feeling
bad oh there it is
herring left and right buddy left and
right look at that buddy
look at that buddy jerem Cup it's down
Gangnam style up there shoot another one
let me Perry man the world
cup hits now another coin
thank you saw you made me waste it I
don't trust you I don't trust you
oh no someone killed him okay here we go
here we go look at the platforming
skills look at this look at the skills
look oh my god no the ball of flame just
came out of nowhere
oh my god no I must be extremely bad at
this game
boo-hoo-hoo I really don't back up my
claims with the gameplay do i oh my God
look at that dude look at that how do I
get up there know it I'm fine I'm fine
what is happening what is happening oh
my god you're killing all my friends I
will have to dump you my cow may have me
hot I was not ready for a boss battle I
just that's gonna hit me you dead please
be dead
thank alone thank you little place
impossible jump oh my bladder blood me
Sigma breast bellissima a grassy Miller
chhoti Oh give me that answer power can
see those skills game journalist you're
never gonna get sleepless I showed you I
showed you long range with below okay no
smoke bomb yeah I want that one
[Music]
invisible - that's pretty good
oh that's disgusting
you're disgusting he's not you a again
we're gonna go I'm gonna go up or down
huh how's shoes oh wait they explode oh
shoot
I just got busy
what is happening oh my god what is he
doing is he stuck oh my god what is
happening what is he doing okay this is
different oh wow okay
[Music]
fine
shoes nope
oh this is a tight one
it's a real tight one boys shoes yes got
it that's oh my god this is why flowers
shouldn't have teeth right there a walk
in the park
first try first try are you paying
attention journalist first try so easy
my God look at that a-plus I love this
game it's so fun
skip boss option my god well look at
this area oh why you still say it okay
let's go help the mouse
I am literally stuck this game is
absolutely awful this is the worst game
i have ever say I'm stuck
0 out of 10 worst game I take every
praise back I take it back god damn it
there's a glitch in it
where's the skip boss vital button why
can't I just skip the entire game huh
where's that option huh you can
fast-forward a movie right huh you can
fast-forward of the movie why can't I
just fast-forward a game huh huh that's
legit criticism they used oh cool
what I don't I did it
what how do i Dutch oh I don't know what
I'm doing I do I shoot the duck sir I am
his doodle taken Oh God don't know what
to do let you poop on the be vehicle
what the heck just happened
oh ho what seriously where's the skip
but I don't want this come on dude sucks
this sucks this one is really not that
hard at all
yes that's right stupid photo what now
what now oh my god I don't know what's
happening all I know is I could die any
second
that's a bit creepy oh wow okay
[Music]
all right very fast train okay and I'm
dead god damn this one is difficult
compared to the other ones zero deaths
okay zero deaths I got it now I get it I
get it I got it
again I mastered it I mastered the Arts
I mastered the urge all of them all of
them at the same time look at that I
missed that move on purpose and then why
Stewie's too easy take this stupid bit I
hate it I hate the super balloons okay
they're annoying they're knowing to me
I'm sorry I hit a little like Vanilli's
very much I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I don't like balloons I'm sorry I'm
killing it though I'm killing I'm not
sorry die please no no thank you
now we got this stupid one yeah I'm
calling you stupid now oh he's gonna
come here now I know you know young your
whip is snappy get it get it right up
your ass
death rise I must be a genius to figure
that out you must be a genius like
myself
come on little penguins
[Music]
I missed come up penguins where's your
little penguins
what are your little penguins huh where
are they
time right I killed penguins what are
you gonna do put it by murder of
penguins polygon you're gonna write
about that you're gonna write about my
no I'm not gonna look and maybe you will
haven't read about that big fight ow
dude last one hit me that was not fair
stop no no I'm not
Berenice very easy oh my god it was so
easy look how much help I have less 500
it said five okay all right fine fine
I'm sure you got a plus the first time
you beat it sure buddy sure buddy
sure sure keep talking keep talking know
what a head is yeah but a bad bad bad
bet a bad bet
alright that's it for me for it for now
I hope you enjoyed this episode leave a
like if you did really appreciate it I
love cuphead you know it's not a game
for everyone but there are games for
everyone so play those instead you're
crybabies Jitsu ow